nos piden resolver para x y nos dan esta
ecuación radical 1 es igual a la raíz
principal o raíz cuadrada positiva de x
sobre 3 menos dos una manera de hacer
esto es dejar de un lado la expresión
radical elevar al cuadrado y finalmente
despejar x esta es la manera más directa
y por lo general obtenemos más de una
solución por lo cual hay que probar las
soluciones en la ecuación original a ver
si funciona en otros vídeos explicado
por qué en ocasiones obtenemos
soluciones que de hecho no llegan a
funcionar pero resolvamos esta debe de
salir directa así es que lo primero para
eliminar este 2 vamos a sumar 2 a ambos
lados de la ecuación sumamos 2 a la
izquierda y sumamos 2 a la derecha que
tenemos del lado izquierdo uno más 2 es
igual a 3 y del lado derecho menos 2 y
más 2 se cancelan y nos queda tan solo
raíz principal de x sobre 3 ahora
multiplicamos por 3 ambos lados de la
ecuación multiplicamos por 3 el lado
derecho y multiplicamos por 3 el lado
izquierdo del lado izquierdo resulta 3
por 3 9
y del lado derecho 3 / 3 se cancelan y
nos queda simplemente la raíz cuadrada
de equis y ahora simplemente elevamos al
cuadrado a ambos lados de la ecuación
elevamos entonces al cuadrado del lado
izquierdo y elevamos al cuadrado de la
derecha del lado izquierdo nos queda 9
al cuadrado es igual 81 y del lado
derecho nos queda x obtuvimos una sola
solución probemos la sustituyamos la en
la ecuación original y veamos si
funciona evaluamos el lado derecho con x
igual a 81 y verifiquemos que esto es
igual a 1
tomamos entonces la raíz principal de 81
sobre 3 este es el valor de x que
estamos tomando menos 2 y eso cuánto es
la raíz principal de 81 es la raíz
cuadrada positiva esto es 9 sobre 3
menos 29 entre 3 esto nos da 3
finalmente 3 menos dos es igual a 1 de
hecho es igual a 1
así es que efectivamente x igual 81 es
una solución válida
radical